and what is bioinformatics is the
development implementation and use of
methods and software tools for
understanding biological data
bioinformatics has practical applications
in health agriculture and
climate change mitigation as this
field advances bioinformatics
presents several challenges both for  the
students who try to learn there as much
as the teachers who have to teach me
and in this presentation I will explain
current challenges and limitations of bioinformatics I will
describe how we intend to face
these challenges with the logical omx platform
I will also describe
Bloom's taxonomy and how it can be used
in  computer
course and of course we will explore the program the
logic mix and how he uses
Bloom's taxonomy in the structuring of his course Pilar
and in these projects and finally to
write several results of the
logic Amex program So what are some
challenges that the field of bioinformatics
is facing  currently to start
this field is constantly growing
and developing new technologies and
software to improve time
and processing power the
analyzed datasets are usually very
large and consume immense amounts
of computing power and memory that
many personal computers do not have
And furthermore despite  despite being
publicly available the data
are also often complex to access and
programming knowledge is often
required for this similarly
partline analysis programs require
programming knowledge that many
biologists and scientists lack in a
University environment students have the
opportunity to  learn the
basic information to design and implement the
informatics project but do not receive
hands-on experience with
full workflow due to the limitations
that were mentioned earlier
similarly faculty face
challenges to be able to cover a
diverse bed of  topics if you
specialize in a certain area of
bioinformatics or if you are not
familiar with bioinformatics in
general for example the professor whose
research that focuses on the expression of
a cogene to do a lot about the
genomic goal helps
to overcome these challenges
the Max platform was developed  Black
this program aims to standardize
and organize and systematize training
in bioinformatics to make these
analyzes useful for any biologist or
professional in the clinical area
some problems can be, for example,
standardization since the materials seem to
the courses are usually developed
at home taught practically
rarely are  updated the organization
because the challenge is to combine several
different themes and the need to move a flow
and the transitions And also systematization
how you could know is someone
needs help or to allow someone to
move on with a keloid using
modules standardized interactive sessions
starting with  m the mastery of technology
and the concepts to implement these
concepts in with
real datasets and a G1 based approach the
learning process to create a clear
path the development of
skills increase logic employs Bloom
's taxonomy learning levels
this approach begins  what
basics students remember is Facts and
terminology and are able to repeat
memorize material on that basis
learning builds
conceptual knowledge that to be able to
understand concepts and apply
information to new situations the student
will be able to analyze data drawing
connections and evaluate  how to
certain methods and their leads to the
highest level of learning the ability
to design and create original works
And then
how the resources Da umq Logic helps to
advance in the teaching of bioinformatics
man Floyd is a portal for
practical and theoretical pressed bioinformatics
composed by  shorts designed to
take you through conh  theoretical
and methodological foundation combines
training modules data analysis tools
datasets from
selected projects interactive exceptions as
mentors to provide the student with a clear
path in the pyramid of taxonomy
of the globe no matter what is different
initial user with bioinformatics
how can  which is a
useful tool for gaining a basic understanding
of the theory behind bioinformatics
analyzing large datasets
an introduction to basic decoding languages
like r and Python or starting a
data analysis project
and
these six courses are taken from
the core curriculum of the work  ixplode
available online starting with an
introduction to the applications of
bioinformatics and an overview
of data types student is able to
learn terminology and
factual knowledge to build from there
on Genomics
transcriptomics meta genomics genomics
data science each course begins with
terms  and co
important concepts then presents
case studies that go online related to
each one that allow students to
acquire conceptual knowledge to
start their own
projects expanding the basic curriculum with
projects and methods of bioinformatics
Are best learned in the context of
real case studies
prepared by our network of mentors and
collaborators that illustrate how various
bioinformatics methods data types
or mycos are used in current research
and medicine there was technology agriculture
and even astrobiology projects are
prepared taking
publicly available datasets and angles
to explore to understand the  challenge of
research and the path of analysis to
extract in complex man data significant sites
the logical omx platform gives
students options to analyze a
given dataset these
wrong sets and
associated publications can be used in
many ways you can learn  der
bioinformática without any programming
betray each project we explain the Spike
Lines of analysis the way to have bioinfo that
it is friendly for pirate analysis
you can also learn the scripts
behind many of the steps learning to
organize
visualize analyze the data in
popular languages ​​as is  that you do to
create your own analysis and
finally you can hear about the
projects and their research applications and
Our programs guided by mentors
or experts share their
experiences and support
research projects developed by you are
and here is an example of the park there
Independent  programming interface
of its parent builder that it on the
platform had the info is a
color-coded online site that helps to
establish a logical connection between
new technical data analysis methods
and the logical steps required
to build the parent by  incomplete
used Are inserted as an
input file and and  Then the analyzes can
be chosen Based on the type of
research each analysis to be separated into 3
colors blue for pre-processing
red for mapping And provided for
quantification
each time you click a button a
cup find additional information
useful to build the parent  printed
color coded buttons facility allows programs to be
run without any programming knowledge
the man employing a
hybrid approach combining learning and research
to ensure students are
developing the first level
of Bloom's taxonomy the Logical mix that
tracks progress  with activities such
as Pillars Purification
literature review asked about topics
has bushings and important questions and
covers a wide range of topics such as
biomedical research
biotechnology and
agriculture then students are able to
continue their knowledge base with
research assessment making sure
that  are c  able to understand these
challenges and outcomes as well as being
able to understand the
primary research literature they should also be
able to ask questions based on
data exploration
and students should then be able to
achieve the highest level
Bloom's Taxonomy Create  this is achieved by
creating your own analysis project
for example Laura García develop a
project in this project a
random Forest classifier was proposed to
discriminate
antibiotic and non-antibiotic wool bacteriocins based
on amino acid composition
another example was Andressa's project
which  just shared a presentation of a
research project developed in
this Dental research scholarship program
focusing on the
transcriptomic analysis of disease progression
and pathogenesis of alzheimer's disease
your project received great prominence because
it won first place in the Mexican Cup it
has then represented the
international country  mind
Ah and finally the Mari heat project, it's a
pity that VISA developed an
algorithm for better prediction
of membrane markers in
triple-negative breast cancer cells
from transcriptomic analysis and for him the
great result was to present bee
information that  are not familiar with and the big
advantage was the software that works
intuitively and logically is proud to collaborate with
universes programs for example suit
National Association of
Principal Investigators of Ideas is also we
work with more than 15 thousand students in
community colleges with a
community college  from glendale Top
tier university like
George university as well as some
Universities around the world